me
医師の
あっん
北
悩んでるんです
今すっごいやりたいことあるんですけど
でも何から始めていいかわからないしお金もないし経験もないし知識もない
だから諦めようかなってそう思うんです
でもやっぱり諦めたくないんです
こういうふうに悩んでいたのが今から10年前
27歳の時でした
27歳の時の僕は
趣味ではバンドをやっていて
お酒を飲みに行くのがすごく好きで友達と酒を飲みに行ってはよく夢を語っていたん
です
俺1年以内にバンドで絶対成功するから
ライブハウス系でしょうかな
8やっぱり俺アジアン雑貨餌野郎かーっ
いつも中途半端に言ってるわけじゃないですその時は本気で語ってるんです
本気で語って次の日の朝起きてまず
よしやるぞって思うでしょ
でもその次の瞬間
[音楽]
お金もないし
どうやっていいかわからないから
後で考えようって
そう思って
気がついたら7年以上の月日が経ってました
7年間もこういうことを繰り返してやっぱり自分に対してすごい悔しくなって
夢の叶え方っていうのをインターネットで調べてました
インターネットで調べていたら逆にこんな夢をあきらめ始める平均年齢24歳という
ものを見つけました
早くないですか
早いですよねー
よくも早いなぁと思って
でその理由っていうのをもうちょっと調べてみたんですそした2つ大きな理由が出てき
ました
一つが災害能力の限界を感じたから
もう一つが金銭的な問題
この2つの理由だけで70%の人が夢を諦めたって答えしたんです
27歳ときの僕はなるほどなあと思いました
同じいうで僕も夢を諦めようとしていたから
なるほどなぁって思ったんです
ただその反面ちょっと腑に落ちなかったのが24歳とか
25歳とかで逆に自分の才能とか能力に気づいている人とか金銭的に俺お金持って回し
てきておくよまり少なかれ誰もいなかったんですよ
だとしたら
ほとんどの人が必然的に夢をあきらめていくんじゃないかなって
そう思ったんです
そして僕は
自分自身だけはちょっと変えたいなぁと思って
今まで27年間やったことがなかったことに挑戦してみることにしました
それが
初めての海外一人と日でした行き先はカンボジャ
10日母です
実際にこう言ってみると初めて日本語が通じないところに行くと自分の強さとか弱さと
かそういったものに気づいたり
アンコールワット初めて見たときやっぱり感動しました
だけどそれ以上にこの国で感動したのが人でした
人が優しくて自然体で
よく笑っていてその中に自分の身を置いていると自分自身もなんかこう肩の力が抜けて
いって開く自然体でいられるようになっていったんです
そして気がつけば
大好きになってました
人が人を好きになるのと同じような感覚で僕はこの国のことを好きになって好きになる
とやっぱり好きになった人のことを知りたくなるじゃないですか
僕もこの国のことをもうちょっとして痛くなって
観光地ではなくてないところへ行ってみようと思って気がついたら
個人に遊び言ってました
この個人に遊びに行ってた時に僕の人生を変える大きな背中を見せてくれた人に出会っ
たんです
この方は伊藤さんという形で50代半ばの1でした
その1多くはこの時出会う前の10年間
10年間でカンボジアに小学校3校建ててその学校を通してこの国と付き合ってき
たっていう話をしてくれたんです
すごいなと思いました
僕もこの国のことを好きになっていたのでこの国がまだ学校必要だっていうのは分かっ
ていたのでこの国学校をつくってその学校を通して一生多くも付き合っていきたいて
それがこの度中の夢になって日本に帰国したんです
そして日本に帰国したらまた悩みました
なぜかというと蛍雪資金の話だけしか聞いてなかったんです
建設資金は学校建設抱いて150万円ぐらいあったできるようって話をその時きました
それ以上わからないんです
自分の友達とか周りに学校をつくった人もいなかったし
インターネットだいたいインターネット白いているんですけどインターネット調べてみ
ても学校の作り方でてこないんですよ
だから
経験もない知識もない
そして奥には150名てお金もなかったですだから諦めようかなってそこの時は思って
ました
なんですけど実はあれから十年たって
この夢
かなえられたんです
最初にありがとうございますえー何ん
最初に小さな小学校へ2教室の小さな小学校をつくることができてその後は幼稚園を
作ることができたりさらには公園まで作ることができました
そしてその小学校 new とか幼稚園には今まで500人以上の子どもたちが通って
100人以上の生徒が卒業していってます
僕この夢叶えられたんです
でも急にお金とか知識とか経験ってなかなか身に付かないですよね
でもなぜかな得られたんでしょうか
boku no
この考えられたところの品というのは僕の大好きなものになりました
何かというとバーベキューです
僕もバーベキューは昔から大好きでーーーーー
とにかく楽しいですよね
でこのバーベキュー家にへ
日本に帰ってきた時にも友達と言ってました
でそのときになんでこんなに楽しいんだろうなって思ったんです
そしてそれを冷静にこうなんか分析してたんですよね
by を寄付しながらそしたらあることに気がつきました
まずバーベキューってリーダーがいないんですよバーベキューやろーって始めた人が
リーダーではなくて単純に一緒にやりたい人がそこに集まってきてお金をちょっとずつ
出し合って好きなものを買ってきて
バーベキュー場に着いたら
誰が支持するわけでもないのに野菜を切り始めてくれる人とか
食器洗いに入ってくれる人とか子供と遊んでくれ人が炭をおこしてくる人とか
それぞれが好きなこととか出来る事とか得意なこととか求められているところに行って
やり始めるんです
て気がついたらみんなが求めていたものが出来上がっているんですよね
こんなに自由で何かが出来上がるっていうのは楽しすごい良いことだなって思いました
で
この時に置く
あ
自分一人が全部できなくてもいいんだって思ったんです
自分ひとり全部やろうと思ったからああ難しいなあって思ってた
そのことに冷やすいたんですだからこのバーベキュースタイルっていうのを自分の学校
建設に取り入れてみようって
そう思ったんですそしてええええええ
ことかっていうとみんなのできるとか得意ってことを集めてみようと思ったんです
まずじゃあ例えば学校建設資金150万円というのが見えたので
一緒に学校を作りたいという人に
参加してもらおうと思ったですこの建設資金でもそしてほかこんなプロジェクト考え
ました
カンボジャ幼稚園建設1000プロジェクトというプロジェクトです
どんなプロジェクトかっていうと学校一緒に作りたいっていう人が一口1000円から
誰でも参加できて
で専任の人と縁がつながった時に150万円で建設式な
達成しているだろうっていうプロジェクトです
こんなプロジェクトを考えて目標期間半年間で1000人募ることにしました
最初の5カ月間自分なりに一生懸命動いて最初の5ヶ月間400人の人が参加してくれ
ました
っすっ子嬉しかったですでも気がついたらあと1カ月で600人の人が参加してくれる
とこのプロジェクト達成できない
ですよね毎日2020人僕の中ではもう半分諦めてました
なんですけどここから奇跡が起こり始めました
最初に参加してくれた400人の人たちを中心に
僕の私の友達も学校作るため1000円ぐらいと出してくれてもが声をかけてみるって
言ってどんどんどんどん声をかけ始めてくれたんです
そしたら最後の1ヶ月が700人の人が参加してくれて合計で1100人の人が参加し
てくれました
このプロジェクト達成したんです
そして建設資金150万円てた目標にしていたものが実際には200万円以上のお金が
集まってカボチャに入って学校をつくり始めることができました
性格を作り始めると
加茂者度人がたくさんいるんでしょうねとび人が一緒に学校作りたいですって言って
くれたり
日本から建設のために来てくれる人たちがいました
て気がついたらこんな感じで
1弾来る前だいたい毎日20人から30人くらいのを買って建設現場に向かったんです
これだけ手伝ってくれる人たちがいるとやっぱりできることって増えるんですよね
例えば学校汗を流して一緒に形にしていってくれる人とか
その間に美味しいご飯を作って待ってるからねって言ってくれる人
子供とか村の人とかと交流するのがまあ人たちは交流をして関係性を作っていってくれ
ます
さらにやっぱり中には体調悪くなってしまう人もいるのでその体調悪い人にいち早く
気付いて教えてくれる人もいました
こうやって進んでいきましたで更に言うと
村の子供たちもいつのまにかこのバーベキュースタイルに参加して計算す
こんなちっちゃい子がバケツリレーに一緒に参加してくれたりとか雨が降っても子ども
たちは建設やめないんですよね
楽しそうにずっと建設を続けてくれたりとか
おやつのバッターをお腹席そうに見えたのが1個あげる打ってくれたりとか
ちょっと疲れたなぁと思って横になっているとふと横を見ると
こんな変顔してバランスってくれる子たちもいましたこんな感じで
ながら子どもたちも自分たちができることって
て参加してくれてましただからすごい楽しく進んでいったんです
この建設の中で
一つちょっとみんなで実感でできできたらいいなと思ったのでここでちょっとひとつ
質問させてください
この会場の中で学生時代
技術子を取ったことあるって言うかと言いますか
ありがとうございます眩しくてちょっとあまりしていけなかったんですけどこの蛍雪中
の時にもだいたいこのぐらいはリアでした
30人くらいいる建設雌花家4人の子が手を挙げてくれてこの子たちに置くこんなお
願いをしたんです
この真っ白な壁にめちゃくちゃ可愛い世界地図書きたいから宜しく打ってそしたらあ
わかりましたができることはすぐ答えてくれるんですよ作戦会議で始まってすぐ下書き
をしてくれました
下書きをしたところで今度美術子じゃなくてもいいんです
色を塗っていきます
そして色を塗り終わった時ぐらいに世界中の子供たちが手つないでる a 書いたら
もっとかわいくないですかってアイデアも出てきて備えを入れました
で最後にこの学校ができていっ
この村の子供たちが字を読めるようになったらこの絵の意味が本当の意味がわかって
くれたらいいねって言って向こうの言葉クメール語世界は一つという言葉を入れて
出来上がったのはこんな壁です
すごいですよねトップ下と本当にこの壁の絵大好きなんです
これって
得意な人ができる人が中心になってやってくれたからこういう壁内になったんだと思っ
てます
もし
僕がこの壁姉の中心になっていた絶対できなかったと思ってるんですね
なぜかというと僕ない心ってこのぐらいなんです
もはやもう何か分からないですよねいやーって書いてあるからもうちょっと想像今して
もらえるかなって思うんですけど
屋内心ってこのぐらいなんであのみんな同じ気持ち今なったと思うんですよか中心だっ
たらさっきの壁ないは絶対できてなかったと思いますこういう形でそれぞれができると
か得意っていうこととかやれることが
歌っていて建設は進んでいきました最初は何もないとか穴掘るところから始まって
土台をつくって
柱をつくって屋根を作って
壁とか扉ができて3ヶ月後
こんな素敵な学校が出来ました
そしてこの格好めちゃくちゃ素敵なんですけどこの学校ができたと同時に村の人との
関係も出来上がってました
僕学校を作りたいと思ったときにここまでのものが出来上がるって関係性もそうだし
建物もそうだし
出来上がると思ってなかったんですねそれははるかに超えるものが出来上がりました
これっていろんな人が手伝ってくれたからなんです
この学校建設を通して感じたことを実感したことが一つあります
自分にお金とか経験とか知識がないからって言って夢をあきらめる人なんかどこにも
なかったんだなって今思います
なぜかというと自分にできなくても絶対誰か出来る人はいるし
誰かができないことってのはもしかしたら自分にできるかもしれないからです
だからもし
今何かやりたいなーって思うことがある人がいたらこんな感じで
もうバー劇は変わったような気持ちでそれを発信して言ったらその有名とかに共感して
くれる人が少しずつ現れていって今できないって思っていることができるようになって
いくんじゃないかなって思いますこのことは翌10年前に気がついて
いつも何かをやりたいときは自分だけじゃなくて自分の周りの人たちのことも信じる
ようにして
それを発信していってますそしたら小学校と幼稚園と公園を作ることができたんです
最後になりますがちょっと想像してほしいです
今もし自分に夢があるという人はその夢を
もし昔持ってたけどそれを諦めちゃったなって思ってたその夢を
それがなかったら自分の周りでこんなことやりたいって言ってその人の夢って
めちゃくちゃいいなぁって事はその夢よ
もし今想像したことを一人でやろうとしたら
難しいなって思うことた分たくさんあると思うんです
でも例えばでしょ
例えば9会場にいる
100人の人たちが
その夢を応援していく応援するよって言ってくれたら
なんかできる気がして来ないですか
他こうやって
一人一人のできるとか得意ということが集まって繋がって
今まで叶えられなかった夢が叶えられて言って
形になっていくことで
少しずつ少しずつ今よりもっといい世界が生まれていくんじゃないかな
そう信じて今日ここで的侵襲でお話をさせていただきました
みんなのできるでかな夢ありがとうございました
[拍手]